driving it back half feed in front was cauter a
good setup looking for William Carlson tipped in
front Carlson what a stop side of the net and
robed by Primo up the right wing lost the puck
Vegas quickly in transition led by Kier with
walk Kier cutting in tries to tuck his short
side penal coming up Mel at the line holds it for
Vegas brings it in near Sur Mel right in front
what a pass to Carlson again tonight by Primo
young man feeling it early [Applause] tonight
Marian St in front and again swinging a miss
that time Carlson's had some good looks early
in this period they are going hard laterally
Stone in right in front another stop right P
save on Carlson we talked about Kaden's first
win of the Season it felt like a home win in
Detroit he grew up just 30 minutes from the
rink in Michigan little sees Arena and he
was outstanding for his first win as Suzuki
on the puck he gets drilled by eel Suzuki on
his skates able to free it re shot score Alex
new hook with the rocket and it's one- nothing
Montreal Nick Suzuki does a good job in a
battle behind the net it's taken down by
eel little pass here two hard steps out and
a shot through a screen lindra hit by kisar
strench pass to vorak and he's in Christian to
vorak forehead and in the pads of Aiden Hill he
was looking back he was squeezing caught her back
on the buck no leave it Alec Martinez take the
shot then throws it in monan there Carlson right
on and Primo kicked that aside Anderson trying to
free it for new hook Anderson giving a AIO grief
and Suzuki holds it in across new hook the lay far
boards in front kevich rot score shot of in kovich
first of the Season Two to [Applause] Montreal
but more and a rush he jumps up in the play so
well a little bit of a broken Play In the Zone
nice Patience by Alex new hook the puck comes
across hits escate he's looking for Anderson
coming across not able to get the puck there
kovich picks it up and rips it inside the post
and one last rush in the five on three
kisar is ready to come out mat what a
move Cuts in shoots left P stop Hill bfield
mat protects the puck at the line another
good spin move Mike Mat R shot up high
and he missed the mark on hill and the
other way kisar some speed he breaks in
short-handed Bret how and Spade sh score
shorthanded goal as Bret Howen gets his
third of the year and Vegas cracks one by
Primo he basically bailes lets Primo
handle the shot so he doesn't screen
him and it squeaks through the right arm
watch here as Kar comes up the boards and
he opens up so Primo would have to keep
an eye on him Evans eel L it ships it
to are trying to break in he's got space
yesie Ulin to the four half score what a
[Applause]
[Music] goal I'm not sure Aiden Hill would have
too detailed a book on Jessie Ulin but it's a good
play by Ulin Ulin to pop it out in that zone
he has a tremendous shot a far above average
shot and he goes right to it full confidence as
soon as he settles the puck here he's going top
[Applause] shelf marsho in and he
wins the draw against Monahan Jay
pedor little stutter step shoots
hit McNab followup score quick
response Bren McNab his first of
the season and it's a 3-2 hockey
game McNab just one goal last year in 82 games
so he's matched that total up to seven points
weard Kum oh what a stop unbelievable as dorak
robbed by Iden Hill here's a look hard wrap by
kovage comes around right out in front of the
net and he's got to settle it first that's the
McNab in the corner Pearson looking to finish
his check comes to kovich at Center barbashev
digs it free with Maro Maro in shoots score
beautiful pass and Jonathan Mara so s on the
season and we're tied up at three nice chip
by Jake Evans in comes petta McNab to the
puck first petta tries to line him up turnover
lindstrm back in for pizetta Evans in front it
again yes ol it doubles down second of the
period and Montreal leads [Applause] again
this one's on the move a sweet dish by Michael
bazetta from behind the net he starts to play
with a hit but what a good hold by Gustaf
Lindstrom to get it back in deep petta with
eyes out in front on the short side he misses
Jake Evans with the pass but right on the
tape Carlson seven shots on goal right now for
Vegas Carlson back on the buck stone
work works it into the corner back
up top R shot the or score Shay TH or
power play goal and we're tied up at
four watch 71 slide right down the
slot vertically the puck gets back
to Theodore he gets that wrist shot
in the third goal by a defenseman
tonight no I don't think Carlson
did get that I think that off the
glove Stone to [Applause] EO eel taking his
time Theodore Vegas being patient here eel
wait shoot score what a rocket up top power play
goal Jack eel and Vegas has the lead with 156 to
go on their fourth goal in their last power
play goal and that time Jack eel makes no
mist take watch this shot uses the screen
of Kaden ghouly puts it up over the glove
nothing for preo yet Montreal controls vahan wed
Suzuki Primo back pedals into his net Here Comes
Thor with Maro deodor Maro shoots what a stop
in the late stages Primo never Sav High gets
across in a big save as Anderson big body
check on petrangelo stretched up to eel eel
Over The Line h on watched by Anderson Stone
RP try in front score the captain Mark Stone
wraps it in another Power Play marker and
your insurance 64 for the defending champs
that time it's the wizard Mark Stone who has
as good a stick as any player in the league
in tight places and he takes the pass behind
the net he's got Justin Baron on his hip and
squeezes him out with the post in comes monam
and Primo to the bench so extra attacker out
HS giving it a go Anderson jumps on the ice
here's mat at the line across for Coffield
makes a shot Barett one time a score don't go
anywhere yet Justin Baron buries one 65 hockey
game Aon sets up in that slot but it's
the patient and poys of Cole Coffield he
takes two steps towards the net that pulls
everyone down and away from Baron and then
lays a perfect pass Monahan in the corner up to
mat slap pass hit tight Suzuki out of the net
Coffield trying to dig it free and time runs out
a late Push by Montreal not enough six five Vegas